se a efe una función que toma valores
reales derivable y que está definida en
r que es el conjunto de los números
reales además sabemos que f de 1 es
igual a 1 ahora si la ordenada al origen
de la tangente en cualquier punto
y aquí nos dice en cualquier punto con
coordenadas x sobre la curva
fx que es la gráfica de la función es
igual al cubo de la abscisa de la
abscisa y así hace tiempo ya no veía
esta palabra abscisa de p entonces el
valor de f evaluada en menos 3 es igual
a y bueno ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es decodificar lo que nos están diciendo
en este planteamiento así que vamos a
hacer un breve dibujo vamos a pintar
nuestros ejes
aquí está books siempre tengo problemas
con pintarlos derechitos vamos a
pintarlo eso ahí está mucho mejor este
es el eje x este es el eje y y nos dicen
bueno vamos a tomarnos una función
digamos digamos esta función
algo así muy bien no nos dicen que
funciones pero digamos que así se ve no
importa ahorita es realmente queremos
plantear el problema y nos dicen que ya
que tenemos esta función consideremos
cualquier punto arbitrario digamos x 0 y
es cero y hay que considerar que la
ordenada el origen de la tangente en
cualquier punto aquí está nuestro punto
y hay que tomarnos la tangente que
esencialmente es la recta que pasa por
este punto con la misma pendiente que
tiene la gráfica
entonces aquí está nuestra recta
tangente
ahí está la recta tangente y nos dice
nos dice que esta recta que de hecho la
recta la podemos expresar como ye igual
a m x + b verdad donde m es la pendiente
y b es la ordenada al origen sin embargo
sabemos algo más quien es la pendiente
de una recta tangente pues la pendiente
de una recta tangente es justo la
derivada en ese punto verdad tenemos que
la derivada es la pendiente de la recta
tangente entonces ya con esta
información ya podemos decir cómo es
esta recta porque la recta sería igual a
m que en este caso es la derivada en x0
de que multiplica a x + b más ve muy
bien ahora como quien sería b quién
sería b esencialmente nos dicen la
ordenada al origen
aquí está la ordenada al origen de esta
tangente que es b sobre esta curva lo
que sea es
al cubo de la abscisa dp muy bien es
igual al cubo de la abscisa de p
entonces tenemos que determinar quién es
la ordenada al origen y entonces por
ejemplo si evaluamos en el punto x 0 y
es 0 pues tenemos aquí que es 0 es igual
a efe prima f prima en x0 por x 0
estamos evaluando en x0 y en 10 0 + b
más ve muy bien esto es para el caso
particular x 0 y es 0 entonces ya con
esto podemos despejar b despejamos b y
entonces nos queda que b es igual a cero
y esto restamos efe prima de x0 por x 0
de ambos lados entonces nos queda menos
f prima de x0 por x 0 y ahora si viene
el problema porque debe ser igual al
cubo de la abscisa pero bueno tuvieras
que es una visa no si tú tienes un punto
digamos 23 esencialmente la abscisa lo
que te dice esto mate la coordenada x
entonces en nuestro problema la abscisa
de bueno de este caso particular sería 2
siempre que te digan toma la abscisa
esencialmente es toma la coordenada x y
la coordenada x de x 0 y 0 pues es
justamente que x 0 entonces esto debe
ser x 0 al cubo muy bien entonces ya que
tenemos esto vamos a dejarme
reescribirlo acá arriba tenemos 10 0 -
efe prima de x 0 multiplicando a x0 es
igual a x0 al cubo muy bien entonces
ahora pensemos en lo siguiente nos
tomamos un x 0 y es cero particular pues
en realidad puede haber sido cualquiera
verdad entonces en vez de ponerles los
ceros digamos como subíndice esto puede
pasar para cualquier punto entonces en
realidad esto es menos bueno aquí hay
que notar algo verdad que es igual a fx
y aquí está y es igual a fx y entonces
que prima es igual a efe prima de x muy
bien entonces tenemos que menos f prima
de x0 en realidad es de prima verdad que
multiplica a bueno déjame ponerlo
primero así esto es caps ya me pase
esto es igual a menos f prima de x que
multiplica a x verdad porque en realidad
puede ser cualquiera y esto es que esto
es igual a y quizá al cubo y ahora f
prima de x dijimos que es mi prima
entonces tenemos ya menos prima por x es
igual a x al cubo y esta es la ecuación
que tenemos que resolver si te das
cuenta es una es una ecuación
diferencial pero bueno vamos a
desarrollarlo un poco más por ejemplo si
dividimos de ambos lados entre x
tendremos y entre x menos ye prima es
igual a x cuadrada muy bien y dividir
entre x porque quiero digamos despejar
la ye prima muy bien entonces por
ejemplo restamos ahora de ambos lados y
entre x y nos queda menos ye prima igual
a menos y entre x mas x cuadrada muy
bien y ahora multiplicamos por menos uno
de ambos lados y tenemos de prima igual
a de entre x - x cuadrada y esto que
obtuvimos ya es una ecuación diferencial
nos dan
la derivada de una función en términos
de la misma función que no conocemos y
de la variable independiente que en este
caso sería x y bueno aquí tenemos un
problema porque bueno si si si esta
parte el menos x cuadrada no apareciera
sería muy sencillo de resolver fíjate
tenemos la derivada de ye que es de y
entre de x verdad esto es la derivada de
y es igual si no tuviéramos esta parte
tendríamos que es igual hay entre x
entonces lo que podemos hacer es dividir
entre y y multiplicar por de x es decir
de x entre y así de ambos lados verdad y
entonces que es lo que tenemos las de x
se cancelan de este lado y las jie se
cancelan de este lado entonces tendremos
uno entre y de iu es igual a 1 entre x
de x y si integramos verdad si
integramos entonces esto es muy amigable
porque sabemos integrar uno entre ella y
sabemos integrar uno entre x aquí hay
que tener cuidado realmente
esto es mnemotecnia y funciona muy bien
en realidad ahí hay cosas como cambios
de variable y demás pero bueno no quiero
meterme mucho en esas cosas el detalle
es que tenemos que resolver está este
problema la integral de uno entre ella
es igual a la integral de uno entre x
entonces la integral de uno entre ellas
sería el logaritmo natural de i verdad y
esto sería igual al logaritmo natural de
x más cualquier constante pero cualquier
constante digamos lo podemos expresar
como el logaritmo natural de una
constante verdad entonces digamos que es
esto el logaritmo natural de y es igual
a la suma de logaritmos es el logaritmo
natural de un producto verdad el
logaritmo natural del producto y esto
nos está diciendo que ya es igual a c
por equis y esto fue muy fácil si no
tuviéramos el menos x cuadrada pero esto
nos va a dar mucha intuición de cómo
poder resolver este problema si pensamos
en que es como una suma de dos
soluciones digamos o algo así
en realidad lo que podemos hacer es
proponer allí como como digamos si
queremos que obtener un algo relacionado
con x cuadrada entonces podemos proponer
allí
como algo x x al cubo verdad para que a
la hora de derivar nos quede como
digamos en términos de x cuadrada verdad
ahora como tenemos y entre x sabemos que
la solución de esto es algo por x
entonces vamos a proponer algo por equis
y bueno vamos a sumarle una constante
sedesol o por sólo por si acaso verdad
entonces vamos a ver
queremos que satisfaga esta ecuación
diferencial entonces sí derivamos la ye
yé prima quien sería sería 3a por x
cuadrada
y ahora quién sería entre x y / x pues
es dividir esto entre x tendríamos a x
al cubo entre x es x cuadrada y de entre
perdón de x entre x pues es b y ahora c
/ x sólo nos queda ce / x muy bien y hay
que restarle x cuadrada es decir ya
sustituyendo esto estos dos en esta en
esta ecuación tendremos déjenme ponerlo
así tendremos 3a x cuadrada + b y esto
debe ser igual a lo que tenemos de este
lado que es a x cuadrada más b más c / x
y ahora hay que restarle x cuadrada
verdad aquí tenemos que restar x
cuadrada
y restamos x cuadrada muy bien entonces
ahora lo que nos falta es determinar a b
y c para que esto se cumpla entonces
sigamos desarrollando y nos queda 3a x
cuadrada más b debe ser igual aquí
podemos agrupar este término con este
término verdad porque ambos tienen x
cuadrada entonces nos queda a menos 1 x
cuadrada muy bien + b
+ c / x muy bien entonces ya podemos
resolverlo porque hay que igualar los
coeficientes de estas dos ecuaciones
verdad entonces primero hay que notar
algo b pues es igual a b entonces eso no
nos está diciendo nada de puede ser
cualquier cosa me puede ser cualquier
cosa
piensa no importa lo que pongamos ahí se
cumple ahora bien de este lado tenemos c
/ x pero del lado izquierdo no no no
tenemos nada que involucre x en el
denominador entonces lo que podemos
decir es que se es igual a 0 muy bien y
ahora nos falta sólo determinar a como
determinamos a pues por un lado tenemos
que 3a verdad hoy este color está muy
feo
a ponerlo con rosa 3a creo que creo que
está también muy fresco entonces 3 a
debe ser igual a a menos 1 verdad porque
es el coeficiente correspondiente con x
cuadrada entonces si restamos a de ambos
lados tenemos 2 a es igual a menos 1 y
si dividimos de ambos lados entre 2
tenemos a es igual a menos un medio muy
bien
tenemos a igual a menos un medio y con
esto ya podemos encontrar nuestra
solución porque es igual a dijimos
fíjense yes a x kubica pero a es menos
un medio entonces es menos un medio por
x cúbica más b que hasta ahorita puede
ser cualquier cosa más bx y laxe dijimos
que es 0 entonces ya tenemos como es y
excepto que nos falta determinar b así
que hay que agregar la condición inicial
que nos diga que f evaluado en uno es
uno quiere decir que cuando x es 1
entonces de este lado cuando x eso no es
menos un medio por uno más b por uno que
debe ser uno entonces si sumamos un
medio de ambos lados tenemos que tres
medios es igual a b entonces ya tenemos
también determinado quién es b y ahora
si tenemos muy claro quién es nuestra
función y por qué ya sería entonces
menos un medio de x al cubo más b que
éste
medios de x muy bien
esta es ya nuestra solución ahora
siempre debes preguntarte realmente es
lo que me están preguntando y no es lo
que me están preguntando a ellos no les
interesa saber cuál es la función ellos
sólo quieren saber cuánto vale la
función evaluado en -3 así que si
ponemos efe evaluado en menos 3 esto es
menos un medio por menos 3 al cubo que
es menos 27 más o bueno en realidad y
así si evaluamos es menos tres por tres
medios son menos nueve medios entonces
esto nos dice que ese evaluado en menos
tres es igual a menos por menos nos da
más 27 medios menos 9 medios y esto
cuánto es pues son 27 menos 9 son son 18
verdad son 18 medios y 18 medios son 9
entonces ya tenemos nuestra respuesta
porque lee la función evaluada en menos
3 es igual a 9 y hemos terminado